I've been waiting for this for years now
this is anker's brand new ma Go wireless
battery charger and it runs at 15 watts
of power compared to Apple's which they
themselves limit to just 7.5 that should
mean that your iPhone should charge
twice as fast right well not exactly it
is the first ch2 enabled wireless
battery pack so technically that spec is
legit and you can buy it for 90 bucks
compared to Apple's 100 I test these
with my 15 Pro Max that has quite a
large battery inside but this anchor is
rated for 10,000 milliamp hours Believe
It or Not Apple's is rated for
1,460 so how can I even be comparing
these well inside of here they're
actually two separate packs that gives
it a different voltage than everything
else on the market so if you do the math
we actually get
2,920 of equivalent uh milliamp hours
now if we compare the size you could see
that we have that difference apples is
so thin it is so light it is smaller in
every way compared to Anchor's Behemoth
of a wireless charging pack and just
putting it onto my iPhone it dominates
this whole setup now you can use it in
hand but you definitely feel it compared
to Apple's which is so tiny and so nice
connected to your phone now anchors does
have a few more features compared to the
Slick minimalistic apple one now on the
back we have this kickstand and that is
absolutely nice if you're going to be
charging up your phone and you're going
to be watching some videos either in
landscape or in horizontal like this so
that is a nice feature and with that we
actually have a display on the side I
love this because when you have it
attached to the back it will tell you
how long it will last more on this in
just a bit and if you're charging it
with USB type-c it will also display how
long it takes to charge by the way takes
close to 2 and 1/2 hours compared to an
hour and 15 minutes for apples the max a
pack does use lightning but it has a few
tricks up its seve which I'll leave for
a little bit because I want to get to
the charging test now for the phone to
power up it took a minute and a half
compared to just 30 seconds for the ch2
enabled anchor charger that right there
is an impressive difference and after
the first 15 minutes Apple's charger got
us to 7% but anchors got us to a massive
177% charge that is an insane difference
and it made me so excited for this new
battery and at the the 30- minute Mark
apples gained 10% up to 17 which is
great but ankors only gained five and I
was like what the heck is going on and
at 45 minutes Apple's reached 26 while
anchors only gained six points so they
are getting very close to the total
amount charged this is where I pulled
out my thermal camera and we got 37°
maximum for apples and that actually is
the same on the back of the phone and
this is the same result that you get yet
using other chargers like their official
Puck whereas anchors hit 40° C on the
battery pack and then the iPhone had
more heat overall so you guys have to
know that with wireless charging your
phone heats up and then these things
slow down and that is what's causing
this thing to not run like it should
I'll actually compare the performance to
anger's new ch2 puck in just a little
bit after 1 hour apples had 36 charge
compared to 38 so they are running very
close here and that just shows that in
the beginning we had a huge boost with
15 watt but at the end they basically
equal out they both gained 10% there and
at 1 hour and 15 minutes we had 41 for
apples and 43 for anchors so the
charging performance is identical now
this is where Apple's battery actually
died and it did not charge my 15 Pro Max
more than 41% while of course we have a
lot more battery left over in this one
at an hour and 30 we hit 52% and then an
hour 45 we got to 59 then 66 at 2 hours
and at 2115 we have 74% charge and then
it took 2 and 1/2 hours to reach
80% now I want to pause right here and
let you guys know that around this time
we had roughly 35 5 36% battery
remaining and that's a huge discrepancy
cuz the iPhone has roughly 4,400
milliamp hours this thing is rated for
10,000 well the rating here isn't true
because the voltages don't match up so
it's actually lower when you're charging
an iPhone and because it's a wireless
charging pack you are going to lose uh
battery to heat also the conversions and
everything else and even though anchor
on the website shows off the special
chips and everything else you still have
a lot of power loss now when you do the
math this thing took about 7,000
milliamp hours to charge his iPhone
roughly
3500 so we're getting roughly 50%
efficiency up to the
80% Mark and that does not sound that
good and at 2 hours 45 minutes
unfortunately we were still at
80% and I think that there's so much
heat at this point built up and trapped
in here that it is just stalling in out
and know I did not have optimized
charging turned on it just had to cool
down whereas Anchor's official Puck
would cheat to the heat is not trapped
in a bunch of batteries at 3 hours
thankfully we hit 84% and then we hit
88% at 3 hours and 15 and 96% at 3 and2
hours and this is where this thing
actually died it hit 1% we stopped
charging on my iPhone and that is the
most that it could charge so when we
look overall we do have this one that
can go up to only 41% this one hits 96
that's more than twice as good but when
we convert the milliamp hours this thing
has triple the capacity so there is a
lot of inefficiencies in here where
you're not maximizing it so technically
if you have a 15 Pro Max and you want to
buy one of these you are only going to
get about one one full charge now
thankfully on the bottom of this thing
we have that USB type-c port and you can
grab a cable and plug in your iPhone and
not use the wireless and then you will
get closer to two full charges from this
battery pack instead of about one that
is way better and this is one area where
anchors actually smokes Apples because
you cannot get any power out of this
lightning Port uh it's just power coming
in now both of these can actually uh do
pass through charging so you can use it
as a nightstand charger plugin USB
type-c and it will charge up the battery
pack in your phone and because has 15
watt um it will charge it fairly
decently not as good as the puck and
with that mentioned let's take a look at
the performance difference surprisingly
at the start the battery pack does
better but then as it moves on we have a
different in charging speeds especially
at the end there and because of the heat
that's built in if you think that this
will perform the same as other ch2
wireless chargers it will not so don't
get your hopes up now there is one cool
feature with Apple's if you plug in your
lightning or USB into your iPhone
overnight it can actually reverse
wirelessly charge this battery pack so
you'll wake up to both being charged but
you can't charge this on a wireless
charger on fortunately so what did we
learn with all of this well even though
we now have 15 watt wireless charging in
a wireless battery pack because of all
the heat that's created when you're
doing that your efficiency goes down the
drain and previously I actually tested a
5,000 Mah anchor battery pack that one
was a 5 wat rated and it could charge a
phone like this up to about 87 not far
off from this 10,000 milliamp pack back
and because of that and because of how
thick and heavy this thing is honestly I
don't think that it is a great purchase
uh I like the fact that it can output
power actually up to 27 Watts which is
the max your iPhone could take it
actually has 20 watt input but it is
just such an inefficient way when you
have a battery pack so I would not
recommend it I wish that Apple would
make a newer version of this with USB
type-c maybe a little bit thicker with a
little bit more capacity that would be
excellent but until then if you had your
hopes up make sure that you don't
because it's a decent device but it's
not as good as promise so thank you guys
for watching go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one